normally we like to focus this part of
the show on complex depressing policy
issues something fun like a co2
emissions from hearses or space poverty
or the proliferation of special-purpose
taxing districts a topic so boring you
didn't even realize we literally already
did that exact story last year and we
want to keep doing those kind of things
but unfortunately we can't until we
address something even bigger the
concept of reality itself and that is
because of this guy
now since taking office around four
hundred and twelve years ago long has
made it clear that reality is not
important to him think about it he
exaggerated the size of his inauguration
crowd he said the election was marred by
massive voter fraud with no real proof
of that he also falsely claims that that
compared to Muslims it was almost
impossible for Christian refugees from
Syria to get into the u.s. he even lied
about the weather during his
inauguration
it was almost raining the rain should
have scared him away but God looked down
and he said we're not gonna let it rain
on your speech no he didn't but it did
rain while you were speaking that's why
your wife was holding up an umbrella and
people behind you were wearing ponchos
and second if God did lock down his only
thought would have been wait the Mormon
Tabernacle Choir come on I'm sick of
them and I'm God could you not book
silence always silent somehow boycotting
this thing - so so that is where we are
currently at we have a president capable
of standing in the rain and saying it
was a sunny day and before we go any
further Donald Trump lives is clearly
not a fresh observation liberals are
probably thinking well hot plate there
Johnny next you're going to tell me that
Obama is aloof Dick Cheney is evil and
Paul Ryan doesn't climax dude he checks
his Fitbit to see how many calories he's
burned
I know what if you're on the other side
if you're on the right you probably
thinking oh great another blizzard of
snowflakes from last Cup tonight with
Johnny trigger warm and and yes I know
all other President had liked PolitiFact
found that just over a quarter of
President Obama's statement survey
evaluated was some degree or thoughts
but with Trump that number is currently
over two-thirds perhaps that is why one
reporter has been covering Trump found
himself saying this this is what makes
it covering Donald Trump so very
difficult what does he mean when he says
words Wow what does he mean when he said
words we are talking about be president
like hey to the match we've been on four
dates with I asked him if he was going
to hang out this Friday and he said
prolly dot dot dot I'm starving
bicycle emoji poop emoji what the
does that mean what does he mean when he
says what Trump's relationship with the
truth is going to be of profound
importance going forward because any
policy discussion has to begin with a
shared sense of reality and Trump's
reality can change within a single
sentence when you hear four point nine
and five percent unemployment the number
is probably twenty eight twenty nine as
high as thirty-five in fact I even heard
recently forty two percent well
well which one is it better because a
four point nine percent rate might
result in a cautiously constructive
monetary policy whereas a forty two
percent rate might result in the purge
so tonight we thought it would be useful
to try and answer four basic questions
how did we get a pathological liar in
the White House where are his lawyers
coming from why do so many people
believe him and what can we possibly do
about it and to that first question
Trump's lying is obviously nothing new
he has a well-documented 40-year history
of he lied about being invited
on this show and about the ratings for
the Celebrity Apprentice he pretended to
be his own publicist
he's building Trump Tower is not as big
as he said it is the inflated the floor
numbers is 58 storey building became a
68 storey building it made a lot of
sense in his mind because if you're
renting a room you'd rather be on the
14th floor than on the 6th one just bear
a thought for confused
firefighters turning up through that
building the smoke alarms going off in
penthouse B on the 68th floor which is
apparently an alcove studio on the 58th
quick it's an emergency
but lies like that are almost charming
what is less harmless is when he started
lying about the presidents birth
certificate and then as a presidential
candidate started making troubling
statements like these the murder rate in
the United States it's the worst the
highest it's been in 45 years now our
president wants to take in 250,000 from
Syria our gross domestic product a sign
of strength right but not for us it was
below zero who ever heard of this okay
okay so just real quick on those no one
isn't no he didn't and no one's ever
heard of a GDP below zero because that
is impossible
[Applause]
horrified him for office but we were so
accustomed to Trump nonsense people
could just shrug it off as Donald being
Donald even his own advisers like Peter
Thiel argued that people shouldn't worry
about his statement but he didn't really
mean them I think a lot of the voters
who vote for Trump
take Trump seriously but not literally
and so when they hear things like the
Muslim comment or the wall comment or
things like that
it's not the question is not are we
going to build a wall like the Great
Wall of China or you know how exactly
are you going to force these these tests
what they here is we're going to have
we're going to have a saner more
sensible immigration policy oh yeah that
is definitely the sense I got from
watching those strong rally
yes well we're all furiously chanting
build that wall we all understand in
this context wall is a clever use of
metonymy a or a figure of speech in
which one word wall in this example is
used as a stand-in for a singer more
sensible immigration policy now if you
will let's unpack subject and yet the
travel ban literally happened and as for
the wall the wall is getting designed
right now a lot of people say oh oh
Trump was only kidding with the
Watterson kid Idol kid exactly when he
says he's going to build a wall he means
it now it might be 30 feet high and
labels 156 stories but a seal that it's
coming so it was worth taking him
seriously
Trump was telling the truth about his
solutions to the problems he was lying
about and he is now making real policy
based on faith facts which brings us to
our second question where is his
information coming from now Trump
himself has admitted he gets a lot of it
from TV which may explain why he speaks
so confidently about cable news staples
like crime and terrorism but when it
comes to the nuts and bolts aspects of
government like the nuclear triad he
struggles now he famously flopped a
question on the Triad during an early
debate in an exchange that ended like
this as a three legs of the Triad that
you have a priority they want to go to
Senator wrong I think I think that me
look nuclear it's just that the power
the devastation is very important to me
now that is terrifying the components of
that triad are important it is
unacceptable not to be able to name
every stable one of them they are
nuclear weapons not your children what
is her name Donald what is her name
I'll give you a hint it starts with ki
and it's not the other one and you would
hope that as frozen
he's now be getting information from
primary sources and briefings but chump
still watches a phenomenal amount of
cable news his tweets frequently echoes
things that just aired on TV just two
weeks ago he tweeted ungrateful traitor
Chelsea Manning who should never have
been released from prison is now calling
President Obama a weak leader terrible
which is interesting because Chelsea
Manning never used the words weak leader
but that phrase was used on Fox News
just 15 minutes before he tweeted in a
segment which also called Manning and
ungrateful traitor so the president
seems to tweet about whatever
information he just saw on cable news if
someone changed the channel to the
sprout network between Colliers life is
boring even for a transitive sad give
you a sense of just how much he watches
cable you a few hours later he was on
Air Force One and you could actually
hear the commercials from Fox News
blaring in the background that's real
that is the Empire carpet jingle playing
at full blast Trump just made the
interior of Air Force One sound like the
living room of an old person who died
three days ago and who nobody's found
yet he watches so much table TV he
presumably also gets daily briefings
from this guy I'm a professional cowboy
and I use catheters been cowboy in for
25 years I've broken 14 bones had two
concussions and a punctured lung
I know pain and I don't want any more of
it especially when I can okay stop I
have so many questions
is calf a real verb if you've only been
cowboy in for 25 years what did you do
before you were Cowboys and why are you
in a library and one that doesn't want
to overdo it with the book you
fascinates me the trunk doesn't just
watch cable news he also takes
information in from frightening ly
unreliable sources such as Breitbart the
organization which gave us Steve Fallon
C Fallon
now Trump chief strategist Breitbart has
published such pullet for eligible
stories as birth control makes women
unattractive and crazy racists pro-nazi
roots of Planned Parenthood revealed and
hoisted high and proud the Confederate
flag proclaims a glory of heritage you
know the kind of the kind of headline
you see your old high school friends
share on Facebook and think oh that's a
shame
I guess Greg sucks now but the Trump
trust in Breitbart actually goes way
back a few years ago Trump was
challenged by Bill O'Reilly who
correctly pointed out that he's claimed
that thousands of Muslims were seen
celebrating in New Jersey on 9/11 was
based on no evidence whatsoever and this
is how Trump responded why I wrote that
I'm wrong built you know this just came
out from Breitbart I mean literally it
just came out Trump vindicated 100%
vindicated then me afterward thousands
that would have been reported they were
swarming at Dyl this article says they
were swarming all over the place so I
don't know what that means but it means
a lot of people wait holding up a
Breitbart article does not make you seem
more credible you might as well have
gone oh hold on a second bill hello okay
Frank sort is going on right bill what
sort of talk to them
and straight choices yet even worse
because he also cited nautical to
support his Muslims on 9/11 claim from
Infowars a website run by this guy
Hillary and Obama want to make you poor
and pathetic we have all their white
papers they hate you they hate
Prosperity they hate God
they hate children and god damn them now
that man is Alex Jones and that is
actually him at his most preventable
Sammis Alex Jones at a job interview
that's Alex Jones meeting his
girlfriend's parents for the first time
now in his more outspoken moment Jones
has argued that the government has the
ability to control tornadoes that the
Boston Marathon bombing was a false flag
attack and that tap water is a day bomb
and that they are putting chemicals in
the water that turned the friggin frogs
gay and then there is the Sandy Hook
school shooting yeah so Sandy Hook is a
synthetic completely fake with actors in
my view manufactured I couldn't believe
it at first I knew they had actors there
clearly but I thought they killed some
real kids and it just shows how bold
they are that they clearly used actors
now that is not just offensive it's
stupid if the government had actually
hired child actors there is no way their
stage parents would have stopped talking
about it well he didn't get the tide
commercial but he did like a leading
role in a government-sponsored false
flag attack it's the same director who
did the moon landing with very excited
Trump is apparently such a fan that Alex
Jones himself has said it is surreal to
talk about issues here on air and then
was the word here Trump say it two days
later and I'll be skeptical of that if
Trump haven't gone on jeonggi's show and
said this I just want to finish by
saying your reputation too amazing I
will not let you down you will be very
very impressed I hope and I think we'll
be speaking of that you know what I
guess it makes sense the Donald Trump
wants to impress Alex Jones why would
you want to drain the swamp it's not to
eradicate although
gay frogs you say they're you to stay
where you are
this is really dangerous though
because there is a pattern here Trump
see something that jives with his
worldview doesn't check it half
remembers it and then passing it on at
which point it takes on a life of its
own and appears to validate itself let
me try to show you that machine in
action Trump's constant claim that
millions of people voted illegally
originated as far as anyone can tell
from some dude on Twitter who claimed in
November while providing no evidence we
have verified more than 3 million votes
cast by non-citizens the next day
Infowars picked that up and it spread
like jet fuel among the right-wing sites
now it was quickly debunked by multiple
outlets but despite that days later
translated legs Trump started tweeting
about billions of illegal votes and
serious voter fraud in states like
California and by early December people
were on TV expressing similar concerns
voting is a privilege in this country
and you need to be legal not like
California where 3 million illegals
voted where are you getting your
information from the media and that
right there actually answers our third
question of why so many people believe
Trump because if you get your news from
similar sources to him as many many many
people do he doesn't look like a crank
he looks like the first president ever
to tell you the real truth but rumors
can be really tenacious and I'll prove
it what rumor do you think of when you
hear the name Richard Gere well here's
the thing there is no proof that he did
that if you think about it it's
ridiculous have you ever held one of
those things there's no way it was
possible but if the president went on TV
and told you it was true you'd go I knew
it
thank you I knew it finally someone said
it but that loop gets much more
dangerous when you're not talking about
something as silly as gerbils from
validated his supporters beliefs about
voter fraud and in turn they validated
his because even where he was directly
confronted with the lack of evidence
this
how he responded you know it's important
millions of people agree with me when I
say that if you would have looked on one
of the other networks and all of the
people that were calling in they're
saying we agree with mr. Trump we agree
there is more people right but just
because they believe you and you believe
them doesn't make it true
this is like Peter Pan we're believing
in fairies will keep think Abell alone
this isn't a magic thing Peter
she has Lou Gehrig's disease and maybe
instead of clapping you should it on the
ice bucket challenge then she still be
alive I'm sorry Peter
but she's dying think about dying the
Poynting even if you take the kindest
approach here and assume translate an
honest innocent mistake and passed along
a new story without checking it when he
was presented with a lack of evidence he
disregarded that fact at which point he
is lying and it seems no one in the
White House has a problem with that
because when asked to justify the
president's views this is what Sean
Spicer did I think the president had
believed that for a while a
long-standing belief that he's
maintained it's a belief he maintained
it's a belief that he's maintained for a
while as I noted several times now he's
believed this for a long time it was a
comment that he made on in a
long-standing belief I've asked an inch
of this question twice he believes what
he believes based on the information
provided does believe that what does
that mean for democracy I've answered
your question have you know you haven't
Melissa no you haven't
it's hardly the incidence of voter fraud
is a verifiable fact and faith and facts
are like Bill Pullman and Bill Paxton
when you confuse them it actually
matters real people get hurt when you
make policy based on false information
billions will get spent on a wall that
won't work to prevent a crime wave but
isn't happening while refugees sit in
dangerous situations to prevent Bowling
Green style massacres that never took
place
so what are we going to do well the
press is going to be a key element in
helping a sort out fact and fiction and
they are under attack this
administration has seized on small
corrections in news coverage to paint
critical outlets as fake news attempting
to delegitimize all of them and this is
only going to get worse
Steve Palin has already labeled the
media the opposition party although
there does seem to be one exception news
reports said the only seat that was
reserved for the media at Trump's news
conference Wednesday was in the front
row and it was for Breitbart news oh
that is so late and favoritism you are
Snow White
introducing the dwarfs I meet grumpy
sleepy sneezy awesome big dick
calls warf and the three others and
anything off thinking that Breitbart
went out of their way to ask a
challenging question think again
for the state news in all the problems
of the center of the details and course
of the election would reform he
recommends for this industry here and I
actually have to follow up questions
does this feel good and will you let me
know when you're going to come just to
pop my head it's obvious
will they completely seamlessly to my
friend you only go to one source to get
your news from as one congressman
happily pointed out better to get your
news directly from the president in fact
it might be the only way to get the
unvarnished truth getting your news
directly from the leader is basically
the philosophy of North Korea and the
notion that our leaders should be able
to pass on this truth with impunity
should be alarming to absolutely
everybody regardless of politics
Republicans should badly want our sense
of objective reality to remain intact
just in case the Democrats ever find
their own appealing reality star to win
back White House rupaul for instance
makes America fierce again hashtag and
make America peers again but we all need
to commit to defending the reality of
facts but it's going to take work as
we've already seen a protest caused to
legislators and lawsuits are effective
ways to try and drag the administration
back to reality but this needs to go
down to a personal level as well we
should make extra effort on social media
to try and verify stories before passing
them on especially if they confirm our
pre-existing biases ask questions of
yourself like is this a source I know
and recognize has any one fact check
this does it link to primary sources and
do those sources match what the story
says and if you see an outlet repeatedly
getting things wrong and never
correcting it
maybe stop trusting it whether that
outlet is some idiots blog or the White
House and and because I know our
president will not follow any of those
suggestions
partly because rightfully he does not
watch this show so if there is one small
way we wanted to try and sneak some
useful facts into his media diet as we
now know he watches morning cable news
forum
so we've actually created a series of
commercials in an attempt to bring him
up to speed also information shows that
we know he watches every day take a look
the pension catheter patient I'm a
professional cowboy and I use catheters
been cowboy in for 25 years and there's
two things I know I don't like pain when
I cat and the nuclear triad consists of
land-based missile submarine launch
missiles and aerial bombers this
increases our ability to strike back any
event one of those is destroyed and
deters an attack on us or our allies so
that's the nuclear triad in case you're
the kind of person who might really need
to know that all these tunnels in the DC
area until we shut down we also plan to
educate Donald Trump one by one on
topics we're pretty sure he doesn't know
about here's just a space it might seem
like a show of strength to kill the
families of terrorists but according to
the Geneva Convention it's actually a
war crime not all black people live in
the inner city and not all people in the
inner cities are black and there's
something they may not know appetizer
fork entree put now I know we can
sometimes feel as if you are the only
person in the world but as you can see
here there are actually many non you
people we call those other people just
because sometimes it's cold that don't
mean there's no global warming you're
confusing climate with weather partner
Gabon is a country on the west coast of
Africa Tiffany
kill me kisum the unemployment rate is a
carefully calculated measure derived
from a monthly survey conducted by two
federal agencies and has been the
agreed-upon standard since 1948 and that
little fella boy is what we call but the
tourists
just remember Donald if you don't know
it's okay to ask see you tomorrow
[Applause]